I gotta let him get a little closer to  the shoreline before I take a shot so  he's not too far out  don't sink don't sink don't sink I'm a  [ __ ]  so far I've never lost a beaver hunting  them this way I don't want this to be  the first I'm gonna see if I can't cast  out a few times and hopefully snag them  I'll probably end up snagging a damn  branch so awful lot of stuff in the  river  it sucks  ashamed for beavers it's the first  there's some bubbles come up right there  I got it there we go  I got him [ __ ] oh lucky or what  it's not that small  nice nice Bieber  when I first shot him I thought he was  gonna float for me but then he started  to sink real slow and once he went down  in there I figured my chances were  pretty slim but I saw some bubbles  coming up and was kind of a telltale  sign where is that looks like a dynamite  where I wanted right in the ear went in  right here  probably weighs he's a good 4050 pounds  anyway 40 pounds haciendas